I'm going to use red to represent wrong and green to represent correct. If it
turns out the null is true, and there's no significant difference. But we
reject the null, that's making the wrong statistical decision. However, if the
null is true, and then we decide based on the result of our sample, that we're
going to retain the null. Then we made the correct decision. Similarly if the
null is false, and then we reject it, we've also made the correct decision. But
if the null is false and the treatment actually did have an affect. But we
assumed otherwise, then we're making the wrong decision. It's always possible
to make the wrong decision. But we minimize our chances of doing so, when we
have a large enough sample size. When we randomize our sample, and when we
implement proper experimental controls. If we reject the null when the null is
actually true, and we conclude that there was a treatment effect. We commit a
type I error. I'm writing in Roman numerals. And if we fail to reject the null
even though it's false, this is called a type II error.